there's a great and I think it's
Nathaniel West but I think he said
Hollywood's the only place where you can
die of enthusiasm and I just loved it
because it's it's nothing but you know
they love it yeah it's fantastic oh my
God I mean everyone's talking about it
yeah
um oh you should have heard it and when
I told people in the room the room went
you know and you hear all those things
and then
um people can hear that for 15 years and
nothing happens yeah imagine if writing
the life at me it really did frighten me
like I was going to meet these you know
really great writers just to sort of
you know
just to pick their brains or get tips on
how it's done and and sort of realize
they hadn't had anything produced for
like you know extra years and
um
I just I find it really scary because I
just love making stuff of course that
sounds like a really obvious thing to
say but um no but it is it's funny it's
not uh
you say it's an obvious thing to say but
I meet so many people young people
that talk to me and they say you know
they're interested in
they want to talk to me and how do I do
it and I'll say what is it you want to
do and they they it's clear very quickly
they want to be famous yeah and what I
try to
point out to them is you really have to
love making stuff yeah because there's
no guarantee first of all the the fame
thing
um I always try and tell them is
this it's it feels almost like a dental
x-ray you almost don't even feel it it's
nothing you get your table a little
faster at a restaurant and you take a
lot of selfies but other than that
there's not it's a very thin broth
there's not a lot there to sustain you
so you really have to like what you're
doing you're like you have to love the
process some of them get it and some of
them look at me
like I'm a very strange old man yeah why
is he babbling about this stuff I think
that's that's it entirely I think with
um with pulling
I just loved it so much you know I love
the characters and I loved what Dennis
and I were saying and
um it was kind of I I could I could have
gone on doing that for years
and then I found myself in a situation
where you know it's like
I was writing shows I had no idea how it
sort of got myself into that situation
and and just the very thought of doing
something for for years and because
writing is so hard anyway yeah I mean
you really really do have to love it oh
when people tell me
they love writing I'm very suspicious I
think you the first thing you have to
admit is that it's hard yeah and it can
be miserable
and sitting down and facing a blank page
yeah I can think of few things I was
more miserable
I think I did good work for Saturday
Night Live uh when I was young but
being up at night trying to think of a
sketch on that deadline was more
terrifying to me than anything I've ever
done as a performer yeah and you get you
get that that it's a mad anxiety isn't
it yeah and I know you've had that too
you've struggled or you've had and
unfortunately
I've had
um
people say to me when does the anxiety
go away and I've had to break it to them
that if you're it's part of the process
yeah it's the it's the rocket fuel yeah
you need it
um you need to feel bad sometimes in
order to feel good and I'm sure I'm
going to get a lot of people to them you
shouldn't say that that's not true I
don't see another way around it I think
I mean I think your anxiety and some
level of self
I don't want to call it self-loathing
but just
there's part of you that's saying come
on come on yeah you could do better you
need that and when people uh are too
content with the writing process I'm
really suspicious oh God yeah then
you're not I don't want to read it if
you had too much fun writing it some
sometimes um
sometimes it it doesn't feel like you're
being
um truthful or Earnest with that you
know like you're just being a difficult
um writer person but um
yeah I mean I'm never I'm never happy
until I get to the point where it's kind
of it's all done and I've like chiseled
it into something that really yeah I
genuinely do feel like I put my all and
everything into that and all the best
bits out of everyone on the team has
gone into it you know all the way across
the line and finally you know we've done
all that work and it's it's ready to go
and at that point I would be happy
here's when I'm happy I'm happy when I
know I've got it it's on there's a lot
of good stuff on the page and now I get
to edit that makes me happy yeah because
it's going through let's tighten it up a
little more let's tweak this maybe this
doesn't follow that so let's move it
over here because then I know I've got
it yeah now I'm just polishing it I'm
polishing it but it's not done yet
because once it's done I start to get a
little depressed about what's the next
thing so I like that little period it's
I don't know if you've had this but
one of my favorite times is
when I'm done with the performance
and I'm meeting with everybody in the
you know in the dressing room afterwards
and we're going through the the show and
talking about everything and then I know
we're going out to dinner and I get to
have some wine that moment when I'm
wiping the makeup off but I know I'm
going off to dinner and we're all going
to be wise asses but the show was a
success yeah that's a moment that I
absolutely adore yeah and I know it's
never going to be quite that good again
you know until then until I get to the
next one yeah because it can change on a
dime can't it you know like I've had
um you know I've I've been pretty happy
with something and someone's gone in and
and sort of fiddled with it and and I've
watched it and gone I want it's a load
of old I mean this is clearly a a
terrible piece of work and so it doesn't
take much for me to sort of lose my
confidence and
um because I I do think there is not a
huge amount of difference in in you know
when something's good and great right
it's just like detail and you know
trusting yourself and your taste and all
that but I remember back in the day I I
found writing I I it was it was a bit of
a torture because I hadn't figured out
that thing that you just described there
that you can get it all down yeah and
then you start you know the the work of
making a good whereas I would like sit
there and just like try and wait each
word has to be perfect before you write
the next word which doesn't work yeah
which really doesn't work and um yeah it
was actually Dennis um Kelly who I
learned that off you know
um I don't know who he learned it off
but but yeah just get it all down there
and when you feel like there's some
really good
stuff in the mix of all the terrible
stuff then you're not in a Barbie you've
done a great job of finding these other
people because I know you met Rob
Delaney through Twitter and you guys of
course work together on catastrophe and
that's how I met you you came on
promoting that and remember that
grabbing my attention and thinking okay
this person's really special but you you
know Finding voices that you know I can
work with this person yeah this person
I mean it is
finding a good creative partner is not
unlike going on a good date it's just
finding that we've got that freeze on
we've got something yeah next I've been
really lucky I don't know how it's
worked out for me really I mean because
I make a show in in the UK called
motherland and that is with um you know
co-writers as well and um
I don't know I've just gotten really
lucky I think because I do it's a scary
thing isn't it it's a really scary thing
and you know
um any of my writing Partners I've gone
through
um like
you know I've lost confidence with and
myself yeah you know um where I've found
it too hard to sort of say something
that I think is funny just because of
you know just losing my
um confidence but um but it's getting to
that place where you feel like an old
married couple where you really don't
give a you know where you will fart
in front of them and and not and not be
worried you know right if it smells
I I mean that's a metaphor I'm not I
don't fart in front of Rob Delaney or
Dennis Kelly or
well I think you just said you did and
we've got that now I'd like to say we've
got it on tape but I Know It's All
Digital where do I come from a
difference you know you know the thing
of like not being scared of course say
something's cheap but you say something
funny you know all the people that I
love working with uh I love my exercise
is what's the worst thing I could do in
this situation what's the what's the and
I I spin out these wild scenarios of
we're here in a restaurant what's the
worst thing I could do that would end my
end me and it's just something where I
make a complete total ass of myself and
I spin it out in great detail and I can
always see it perfectly clearly and
people will be laughing at that and I
don't know what it is but it's it's this
comfort that I can say these horrible
things to my friends about what I'm
going to do in this restaurant that will
finish me forever
um and uh we talk about it and it's just
a joy it's a joy to have people like
that in your life